[Music]
on average it takes 90 seconds to vote
online and anywhere from 30 minutes or
more if you need to travel to vote in
person in a world where you can hail a
cab Bank and even earn degrees online
how come internet voting is still rare
Estonia is a pioneer example one
Estonian out of three casts their ballot
online we have basically digitized
everything's on the government side
99.5% of transactions like all digital
you can really see paper only happening
in very rare cases the electronic ID
card is key for governments to verify
digital identity this young man in
Belgium recently acquired his own card
and is discovering how to connect it
online while 15 new countries already
have cards like this one Estonia is the
only country to run elections on the
internet on a wide scale though it may
be fast and convenient are these
processes really going to make democracy
stronger no estamos queriendo cambiar la
democracy are represented eva por una
democracy a directa krembos que en rica
sur la decisión con la participation
sido Donna favor si una democracy hora
MEP s want to encourage member states to
embrace these tools while taking
measures against hacking identity fraud
and without leaving anyone behind
you